grabado en piedra como en sus recuerdos
con 93 años el humo cilindro es uno de
los últimos sobrevivientes del
holocausto
con 14 años entró en el infierno nazi
cuatro años de horror shelomó se le
conoció nueve campos de concentración y
estuvo en dos paseos de la muerte sus
dibujos fragmentados como ventanas rotas
reflejan los horrores del pasado
y lo más tranquilo down del papel es el
asesinato de mi padre que pusieron un
tubo en su boca y abrieron el grifo lo
hicieron reventar se desde adentro a
partir de este momento me quedé solo en
el infierno y este es el
de loser en
1945 el homo celular quedó agonizando en
el campo de theresienstadt en
checoslovaquia en medio de los cadáveres
respiraba todavía con comandante se dio
cuenta de que yo no estaba totalmente
muerto y se propuso devolverme la vida
el homo salió del hospital un mes más
tarde pero perdió la memoria durante
siete años el arte fue el camino de
regreso para su memoria traumatizada que
recortes gracias al olvido que pude
reconstruirse y la escultura tomó el
relevo y me permitió vivir eterna de
vivir su madre y su hermana menor fueron
asesinadas en los pits su hermana mayor
sobrevivió
mi fuerza era un tesoro que llevé
conmigo este tesoro era el amor de mis
padres eso me dio luz cuando todo era
oscuro y calor cuando hacía frío de el
saler kan y fedex fue sobrevivir con una
herida que se convirtió en luz en sus
pinturas y esculturas monumentales como
la que se levanta en el memorial de 12
aquí cerca de 100 mil judíos transitaron
antes de su deportación hacia los campos
de la muerte al final de estos carriles
un vagón simboliza este viaje sin
regreso
junto a esta obra de granito son un
permanente llamado a nunca olvidar
[Aplausos]